hello guys Ryan the right here and Jos
your name say say your name and Jessica
Villarreal you Jessica it's like my
birthday so first I've never been on
camera before yeah I never she needs
jeez wouldn't found on craigslist you
found me on craigslist and i was like
hmm this guy didn't ask me for a picture
of my feet or my butthole so I think
I'll respond and come over and I did and
so far he hasn't asked me for a picture
of my feet while here but he didn't
clarify the other thing I didn't ask you
for oh yeah what you said oh you know
you're making me look right now you said
you said he didn't ask for my feet or my
butthole and you said and so from here
and he didn't ask for my feet right you
haven't do you want to say it or
something else I have it for cuz you're
making it sound like I asked you for
some I got oh the butthole part yeah
thank you on it sorry thank you yeah I
must be on to your spam sorry all right
anyway oh hey we're gonna do an unboxing
video today jessica is gonna be my
co-host she'll presented the items that
are in the box I don't know what's in
there she doesn't even know what's in
there super geek box legacy November
2015 here we go save the shirt for last
just giving you a tip anything else you
can go our order you want okay I guess
I'll just open it yeah a card Oh a card
open the blast door so my girlfriend
says yeah I was half expecting a
twenty-dollar bill oh yeah we wish you
in the rebels a Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year for now ok so i guess i'm
gonna give this card away to someone
they gave me a card to give to someone
hello turtle a ver marketing
the little koopa rebels oh that's cool
yeah I can't believe any notice that
they even got like the little nut nose
yeah ah that's clever look at that it's
out of focus will look at it I next 11 I
don't think this is a shirt but it feels
oh okay the bag a tote bag yeah police
public call box not free for you lip
butter Doctor Who Doctor Who Doctor Who
oh my god good thing I got a nerd with
me yeah I know someone who loves doctor
who do you I know lots of people but I
don't okay watch it I know someone who
does that's awesome i'm gonna give it to
them for christmas yeah this is what i'm
talking about the unboxing will give you
great presents to give to people
especially if you get the box for free I
don't know that's a real memory I was it
has to be this I just do this on my own
oh just like everyone else I feel like I
this oh it's a magnet that's no moon oh
it's c-3po and r2d2 you're looking at
the death star and they're on the
nightmare before christmas like oh cool
that's really cool that's a cool magnet
really cool that's a cool piece of art
oh yeah that's an awesome I got
Instagram that oh it is an eye on dog a
lanyard pride pride suspenders right
cool nyan dog that's the cat nyan cat I
know exactly what you're talking about
that's why I brought you here so you can
affirm the thoughts I already have
that's awesome oh yeah we're that I
would support that you would oh and it's
um adventure time adventure time yeah oh
cool do you follow a venture time no
really damn I just know adventure time
this is cool that's really cool Wow
all right all right here we go f1 here
we go yeah trying to like oh what's that
oh the button the button the button what
the Star Wars sit oh cool oh it's the
it's kylo Ren yes yes yes the Death Star
and tie fighters in there that's a cool
pin he's really I know what I'm gonna be
rocking in December when I go to the
movie oh yeah okay yeah aw geez bro now
he's not broken but he's twisted okay
it's twisted up super geek watch he
messed up the boxing here but I love pop
figures i love love love pond figures
it's a c-3po see their bills I was like
uh r2d2 you're a dick you suck r2d2 and
then when aren't you DTS in danger oh no
r2d2 i love you i love you but never
critical i know it's like when he has
r2d2 he pushes him away he's out
attachment issues yeah the marchi gigi
is gone he wants and serious attachment
issues he wasn't raised by a proper
robot I need to fix the boxes of what
you guys did super geek box would you
guys made me do the bobblehead you've
got a red arm they go right arm I don't
think I know that I don't know that
either okay o eb good eating out other
pop figures just like going side to side
mad and c3po so Wow anyway yeah
inspiration right here she the last
thing is the t-shirt let's do this Oh
kind of like a Nike sure the nike it's
kind of like a nike shirt but says sit
there is only passion all right guys all
right Jessica thumbnail time you guys
gonna be so sad as if like that was a
real moment of the video when you saw
the thumbnail but it wasn't all right
cool I could rock this these are really
nice little uh prizes here you know
gifts in the gift box open the blast
door we got Koopa stormtroopers we got
the doctor who police box came in with
this cause and there's like two year old
condoms in this box I have right here
two years old yeah those are expired
never had to use them Oh who uses
condoms who's safe yeah what are you
like on the woman come on guys a hole in
a sheet that's the same anyway guys
that's the super geek box for today if
you guys want a super geek box you can
purchase one in the description link
right at the top of the description link
so yeah you get a super geek box because
it is just as cool as being ryan right
which is like the coolest thing ever
probably the coolest job in the world
probably cuz I'm sad that I'm not you
right now you know you wouldn't be like
the first person to tell me that no man
so hard being you isn't it Ryan some
people just have it all don't they I do
have it all so humbled I mean this box
is only if like a few bucks a month I
don't get it for free huh I don't get it
to let me promote it I mean if you guys
get one it's not gonna better for me hmm
this is really likes doing you think
that's good yeah yeah look at the
message you can subscribe to the real
rejects today become a reject Jessica
Villarreal has a channel called best
game show ever you should check it out
because it's a fun gaming related
channel you guys you stay classy and
remember get one for your own benefit
cuz it's not gonna help me if you buy
one yeah just make sure if you buy one
you get it through the actual
description link but it's not gonna
benefit me thanks for having me on the
show who's good meeting you all I might
get any bugs if you guys buy womens be
honest
he's our eyes it's a lot of money yeah
yeah a t-box no 8080 that's this that's
not bad and it all goes back into the
channel a gallon of gas which is in and
out here in LA didn't have to feed me so
I entertain you anyway take care